-Il a milité à gauche dès le lycée,
multipliant les actions
coups-de-poing à la fac de Poitiers.
Aujourd'hui, mon invité
ne brandit plus les mégaphones,
puisqu'il est président
de la commission des lois
à l'Assemblée.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Sacha Houlié.
-Bonjour.
-Nos téléspectateurs,
depuis 2017,
vous ont toujours vu
avec un costume-cravate,
des lunettes,
les cheveux bien coiffés...
J'ai été surpris d'apprendre
que vous ne vous reconnaissiez pas
dans cette image.
"Je n'ai pas le look
de ce que je suis."
Qu'entendez-vous par là ?
-Dans la vie courante,
je suis un supporter de football,
je suis passionné de cyclisme,
de moto,
que je regarde à la télé
et que je pratique,
et j'adore les courses hippiques.
Quand on me voit avec un costume
et des lunettes,
je n'ai pas le profil de l'emploi.
Je fais très sage.
On a l'impression
que je suis pas
d'extraction populaire.
-Vous faites référence
à vos origines ?
-Non,
parce qu'en fait,
je pense que bien s'habiller,
institutionnellement,
c'est une reconnaissance.
Les ouvriers, le dimanche,
mettaient le costume du dimanche.
Par ailleurs,
c'est pas le costume
qui nous fait oublier
ce qu'on défend
et ce que nos parents
nous ont inculqué.
Je suis assez fier
de mes origines populaires,
même si je n'y fais pas référence.
-Lors d'une interview,
vous avez parlé d'un besoin
de revanche sociale.
Votre engagement politique
a été un moyen
de prendre cette revanche ?
-C'était
mon parcours professionnel.
Quand je suis arrivé
à la fac de droit à Poitiers,
des gens m'ont dit
que je n'avais rien à faire là.
C'était plus cru encore que ça.
J'avais pas les bonnes origines.
A l'époque,
j'avais un cuir de moto
et un casque bariolé.
Ca, pour le coup,
je l'ai fait dans mes études.
J'ai terminé parmi les premiers
à la fac.
Major de promo.
Après, je me suis battu
pour être avocat
et pour,
en tant qu'avocat,
avoir mes clients à moi
en plus de ceux de mon patron.
Je l'ai fait professionnellement.
Après, politiquement,
c'est des combats
sur ce que je crois juste,
ce qui m'a toujours animé.
-Votre mère n'a pas exprimé
une vraie fierté,
quand son fils a été élu député.
Au contraire.
Quelques années
après votre élection,
elle a eu cette phrase
qui m'a choqué.
-Ca renvoie
à ce que c'est, la politique.
Il y a toujours un côté polémiste,
il y a toujours
quelque chose qui fait
qu'il faudrait faire
des coups politique.
Et donc, oui, c'est le côté
"combines" qui colle
à la vie politique,
alors qu'au fond,
il y a plein de gens
qui pourraient faire autre chose,
mais qui ont décidé
de s'engager pour les autres.
C'est vrai que pour ma maman,
qui était institutrice,
il y avait le côté
de la robe d'avocat,
la profession, la noblesse attachée
à ce métier, et le côté député,
où elle me voit plus souvent
sur les marchés qu'à l'Assemblée.
-Vous vous êtes engagé très jeune.
A 17 ans, vous avez bloqué
votre lycée pour protester
contre le CPE,
le contrat premier embauche.
Plus tard, à la fac de Poitiers,
vous avez mené
des actions spectaculaires,
notamment en 2009.
Vous avez lancé l'occupation
de l'aéroport de Poitiers.
On voit ça.
*-Les voitures du milieu...
La Peugeot 104
avec le ballon jaune.
On va à l'aérodrome,
on passe par une porte dérobée
de manière à occuper l'aérodrome.
Le but, c'est de disséminer
le message qu'on a posté,
qui dénonce
la privatisation.
Et là, on rigole, c'est parti.
*Brouhaha
*...
*-SI T'ETAIS UN PEU PLUS GRAND
TU VERRAIS L'ETUDIANT
-Il est là, le vrai Sacha Houlié,
les cheveux en pétard,
le mégaphone ?
-Il y a un peu de tout ça,
mais c'était une façon...
Ce qui est intéressant
dans le reportage,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de casse,
pas d'agression,
pas de confrontation
avec les forces de l'ordre.
Ca dure pas très longtemps.
Au final, le message fonctionne.
On peut avoir un militantisme
qui est joyeux
et qui peut être
un peu spectaculaire,
mais qui, au fond, est pacifique.
C'est presque la marque de fabrique
du militantisme à Poitiers,
avec Stéphane Séjourné,
avec d'autres,
où il n'y a jamais eu de violence.
-Ces images, elles peuvent
faire penser à Sainte-Soline,
contre les bassines
de Sainte-Soline.
-Pas du tout.
-Il n'y a pas de violence.
-Voilà, c'est l'essentiel.
-Aujourd'hui, vous auriez 18 ans,
vous seriez allé à Sainte-Soline ?
-Non. Je pense qu'il y a trop
de violence, trop d'affrontements,
trop d'idéologie autour de tout ça.
Là, on sent qu'on défend nos idées,
avec un message politique
assez fort
sur les moyens des universités,
les moyens des étudiants,
sur la façon d'assurer
un service public accessible,
mais en revanche, il y a
un peu de ruse, un peu de malice.
On contourne
les forces de l'ordre.
On casse rien.
On n'insulte personne.
C'est essentiel.
-Cette période de militantisme
au PS et à l'UNEF,
elle a été décisive
pour votre engagement.
C'est à ce moment
que s'est constituée
"la bande de Poitiers".
On va voir cette bande en images.
Il y avait vous,
mais aussi Pierre Person,
Stéphane Séjourné,
Guillaume Chiche,
Aurélien Taché...
C'est une partie de la bande.
Tous ceux-là, vous avez quitté le PS
pour rejoindre Emmanuel Macron
et vous avez tous occupé
des postes importants,
des responsabilités.
Comment expliquez-vous
ce destin commun qui est quand même
assez hors du commun ?
-Je l'explique pas.
On a tous travaillé pour ça,
on s'est engagés politiquement,
on a suivi des parcours différents
les uns des autres.
C'est une photo au congrès du PS
à Poitiers en 2015.
Maintenant,
on n'est pas tous d'accord.
Il y a des gens encore au PS,
des gens avec qui
on est en désaccord,
mais on était un groupe d'amis,
et on se respecte.
-Vous dites que c'est la loi Macron
qui a fait office de révélation
pour vous.
La loi Macron votée en 2015
sous François Hollande.
Révélation de quoi ?
-En tant que jeune avocat, déjà.
Il y avait des dispositions
pour les jeunes avocats
pour libérer la place,
pour donner à chacun sa chance
en fonction de ses compétences,
puis le fait de vouloir travailler
avec tout le monde,
de pouvoir ouvrir
les chakras, mais même les esprits
des uns et des autres,
et j'ai trouvé ça assez intéressant.
Je l'ai donc soutenu.
Ca a ferraillé, à l'époque,
au Parti Socialiste,
chez les jeunes.
-En 2017, vous avez pris
une place importante,
puisque vous avez créé
Les Jeunes avec Macron.
Ca vous a valu,
après votre élection,
d'être un peu catalogué
comme faisant partie
de la garde rapprochée
d'Emmanuel Macron.
Pourtant,
vous vous êtes opposé à lui,
à certaines décisions
qu'il a prises.
Le premier quinquennat vous a déçu ?
-Non. Pour l'essentiel,
j'ai soutenu le président.
Il y a quelques mesures
où j'ai eu une voix dissonante.
Ce n'était pas les mesures
qui étaient les plus importantes.
Mais sur TousAntiCovid,
des dispositions sur la police,
il y avait des choses
où j'avais des opinions
qui étaient un peu différentes
et je les ai fait valoir.
C'est une façon
de ne jamais renier ses convictions
et de se défendre.
-Vous claquez la porte
des instances dirigeantes...
-Il y avait
le fonctionnement du parti...
-On vous a senti désenchanté,
presque.
-Vous savez, la politique,
c'est quand même assez dur.
On vous demande à chaque fois
de faire des efforts,
de travailler énormément
et de faire des compromis.
Parfois,
il y en a qui sont
plus difficiles que d'autres.
C'est une façon
de marquer les désaccords.
Après, comme vice-président
de l'Assemblée,
comme rapporteur de textes...
-Le plus jeune vice-président
de l'histoire de la Ve.
-J'ai toujours servi pour le mieux.
-Vous avez reconnu
avoir fait preuve d'immaturité
au début du premier mandat.
On vous a surnommé
"le sale môme".
Vous avez changé,
par rapport à ça ?
-Avoir du caractère,
c'est important.
Ensuite, il faut imaginer
ce que c'est, être élu à 28 ans,
avec toute la charge
que ça représente,
y compris quand on est
vice-président de l'Assemblée.
On a pu faire des erreurs.
-Mais lesquelles ?
-Le fait qu'on était un peu
en mode bulldozer.
On voulait prendre la place,
exister politiquement,
on voulait défendre nos idées...
On a pu être impolis
à l'égard de certains ministres.
C'est la vie.
Le but, 1, c'est de savoir,
2, de savoir
ce qu'on n'a pas bien fait
et de pas le reproduire.
-Depuis 2022, on vous a vu
sur la taxation des superprofits,
sur le report de l'âge légal
de la retraite,
sur la régularisation
des sans-papiers
avec cette tribune
qui a été cosignée
avec plusieurs responsables
de la NUPES.
Vous continuez de porter
une voix de gauche
au sein de la majorité,
mais différemment.
Vous avez changé de méthode.
-Je m'assure
que les idées qu'on défend
deviennent majoritaires.
Au départ, on prenait
des objets politiques,
qu'on défendait, et peu importe
quelle était l'issue,
le but était d'abord
de pouvoir défendre
ce qu'on pensait juste.
Là, le but est
de faire progresser les idées.
-De peser réellement ?
-La taxe sur les superprofits,
elle est
dans la loi de finances 2023.
Elle finance le bouclier tarifaire.
On a payé
moins cher notre électricité,
par rapport aux voisins,
car on l'a inscrite dans la loi.
La régularisation des travailleurs
dans les métiers en tension,
lors de sa promulgation,
j'espère
qu'elle pourra l'être aussi.
Le but est de gagner des choses
pour transformer la vie des gens.
Ca prend plus de temps,
mais c'est plus efficace.
-Dans cette stratégie,
il y a ce poste que vous occupez,
président de la commission des lois,
ça aussi, c'est une leçon tirée
du premier mandat ?
-Oui, aussi,
car d'abord,
j'ai travaillé sur plein de sujets
à la commission des lois,
sur des choses anonymes,
comme le droit des contrats,
mais ça protège les plus faibles
lors des contrats d'adhésion,
c'est-à-dire
quand ils vont acheter un téléphone
ou souscrire
un contrat d'assurance.
J'avais fait des choses
sur les collectivités,
pour les relations entre les mairies
et les intercommunalités,
et j'ai repris,
après la vice-présidence
un bâton de pèlerin
en travaillant le fond,
des idées...
-La commission des lois,
c'est un outil, pour vous ?
-Tout le chemin accompli
pendant le premier mandat
en travaillant sujet par sujet,
un peu dans l'ombre,
avec pugnacité,
ça a permis de construire
la présidence
de la commission des lois
et de connaître les sujets
pour être efficace.
-Ugo Bernalicis dit de vous :
"C'est le moins pire
"des macronistes."
C'est un compliment ?
-Je pense. En tout cas,
je le lis comme ça.
Je le remercie
pour le commentaire.
Je pourrais lui dire que c'est
le moins pire des mélenchonistes,
mais il y en a d'autres
avec lesquels je m'entends.
Ca montre aussi qu'on essaye parfois
de mettre son étiquette
dans sa poche
pour avancer.
-On passe au quiz.
Vous allez devoir
compléter des phrases
que je vais commencer.
On va commencer par parler de foot.
Vous êtes un grand fan
de l'Olympique de Marseille.
On y va.
-Euh... C'est bruyant...
Et c'est...
Il manque presque les fumigènes.
-Il paraît
que vous en avez déjà craqué
dans les tribunes ?
-Deux fois, oui.
-Avant ou après
votre élection ?
-Il y a prescription.
C'était entre 2014 et 2015.
La saison 2014-2015.
-On continue. "Quand on me compare
à Harry Potter..."
-Ca me fait plaisir.
Ca veut dire qu'il y a quelque chose
d'un peu magique.
Il y a quelque chose
d'un peu magique dans la politique,
parce que le fait de pouvoir changer
le destin des gens,
ça s'apparente à de la magie.
-"Faire de la politique,
c'est renoncer à..."
-Euh... C'est beaucoup renoncer
à sa vie privée.
C'est assez pesant
pour ma famille,
qui lit des choses
sur les réseaux,
et pour ma femme, qui aimerait bien
qu'on ait plus de temps à nous.
-Merci beaucoup,
Sacha Houlié, d'être venu.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...